Dad! Do something about Soichi!
Easier said than done.
He's a completely lost cause.
What? Then I'm moving out!
No, wait, Koichi!
I have an idea.
I know a carpenter.
I'll have him soundproof your room.
How about that?
I guess.
I'm home.
-Oh, Koichi.
-The carpenter's here already?
That's right.
Your father had him come right away.
Really?
Mr. Tagaisu, I made some tea.
Please take a break.
Hey!
Hello there!
My, oh my.
Mr. Tagaisu, thank you for coming.
So this must be your eldest son.
Leave it to me.
I'll use the latest techniques
to make your room perfectly soundproof.
The latest techniques?
That's right.
I'll use four-wall construction
to block external noise.
Four walls? That's really something.
There's a reason I chose the number four.
The Japanese pronunciation
of the number four means "death."
Two or three-wall construction won't do.
It only sounds like death
once you have four walls.
Right…